what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Dr Doom the conclusion and
the ending of this is crazy it's amazing
right but to get everybody caught up
because it's been a little while since
we did this that the Doctor Doom story
really kind of has two stories going on
at the same time the first is the
antleon collider storyline and the
second is what's going on with Dr Doom
that what had happened with the antleon
collider is this was a scientific
experiment right it was headed up by
Reed Richards of the Fantastic Four and
other other world-renowned scientists
and it was really just like the pursuit
of Science and how to deal with matter
that would otherwise be impossible to
dispose of and different things like
that the Doctor Doom portion is
interjected when a coup d'etat in
latviria originates in the neighboring
country of sankaria and those
individuals who wanted to seize control
of latviria effectively snuck in and
then launched missiles from latviria to
the uh to the Moon which basically
ruined the experiment but created an
artificial black hole and so the black
hole is basically growing in Mass to the
point where it'll suck up everything in
the solar system but because it
originated from Liberia everybody
thought it was the fault of Doctor Doom
so he had basically been on the run this
whole time well the way this picks up is
it picks up with Adam Brashear the blue
Marvel basically traveling into the
black hole for the purpose of using his
power to try to cancel out the black
hole and then literally dissipate it is
basically what would happen for Dr Doom
he's returning to latviria now so what
we're going to do here is is with the
Adam Brashear portion it's not overly
necessary at this point in time but the
whole just behind this is that as he
travels into the black hole that the
mission again is for him to basically
expand as much of his energy as he
possibly can literally Channel it
outward inside the Event Horizon of the
black hole or really inside the
singularity and then basically collapse
the black hole and then make it out
before he's ultimately destroyed now
obviously this is a Marvel comic it's
defying all laws of physics as we know
them because nothing escapes a black
hole that's the significance of a black
hole so as as Adam Brashear gets into
this there's a few things that happen
one he's met by an alternate reality
version of Otto Octavius and that's when
we end up finding out these different
visions that uh that Dr Doom has been
having over the course of this story
where he has like a different life he
basically leads the world into a kind of
scientific Age of Enlightenment really
where he has like a wife and children
and so on that's what's on the other
side of this black hole it's a wormhole
is really what it is right it's a tunnel
that leads from the main Marvel Universe
to this alternate reality and that
what's been happening is Dr Doom has
been receiving Visions from this
alternate reality of what his life in
that Universe looks like but the other
part of this and for reasons that I'll
never fully understand Christopher
Cantwell invokes The Brood right so like
this crazy looking alien race like
attacks and of course Adam Brashear
basically fights them off but it also
leads to uh Dr Octopus being killed in
the process right this alternate reality
Auto Octavius being killed but before we
find out what really happens there what
we end up doing is jumping back to
Victor Von Doom right now with his
arrival in latviria you do have what are
basically is kind of inner Council right
so you got Boris you got Petra Lara and
a few other people but you also have
Christoph Bernard now the reason why
these guys matter is because one
Christopher nard is the heir to the
throne so as soon as this coup d'etat
happened Kristoff Bernard was like
Public Enemy Number Two Dr Doom of
course being Public Enemy Number One
because he was still alive out there
somewhere but Christopher nard is like
the adopted child of Doctor Doom and in
fact he's gone so far over the course of
his publication history to take his own
mind and use Christopher nard as a
backup for it so as we saw in Jonathan
Hickman's Fantastic Four for example if
something happened to Doctor Doom and he
lost his level of intelligence he could
download his mind from Christoph Bernard
and it would be like restoring your PC
right that's literally what it is here
and so Christopher nard is so important
because he's the rightful heir to
Liberia now you've also got Zora also
known as victorious she was at one point
a kind of Herald to a degree free of
goliathus when he showed up on Earth but
has largely been like the number two in
terms of doctor Dooms control the
military and so on one of his most
trusted confidants but that's really
what's Happening Here is because when
they're out there just kind of surviving
and whatnot and Dr Doom shows up on the
scene it's Doctor Doom riding a bear
which is probably one of the most baller
things that I think I've ever seen
doctor do I mean he just looks menacing
right like literally he's like riding a
bear and he's like I have returned and
like you see that and you're like yep
he's returned and we're not going to
argue with that are we guys and it's
like nope we're not gonna argue with
that at all because the Dude is riding a
bear and none of us wants to die not
only that his bear is his pet he named
him right like literally his name is
Novak
and it's not even his pet he's like this
is my comrade Novak see that he's fed
right so like it's one of those cool
things because for all the the the pop
and Circumstance and all the arrogance
that Dr Doom puts out there to the world
the reality here is he's gooey on the
inside right he's he's gooey soft right
gentle he's he's he's he's he's got a
little a little bit of uh what a
sensitivity on the inside there right so
you wouldn't know it right but it's one
of those those funny things so as soon
as he arrives here what he says and
literally addressing his inner counsel
is he's like this coup d'etat originated
from inside uh latviria as far as I'm
aware and of course it started in some
Korea but the reality here is that I
ruled this country with trust I trusted
my people I trusted that they would not
overthrow me now he does trust to a
degree but he also recognizes they could
do that and in fact that was highlighted
in Hickman's uh of Avengers and New
Avengers when he was talking oh my God
when he was talking to Neymar's
Submariner in one of the best moments
ever so literally like when the
Multiverse falling apart and after the
name of the Submariner had made his
alliance with like Thanos and all those
guys only to find out that Thanos is
exactly what we thought he was which was
just a crazy guy that loves to kill
stuff he abandons the cabal he shows up
at Dr Doom's doorstep and he's like
you've got to help me and Dr Doom is
like uh okay so here's the thing Namor
I'm a king you were a king Once Upon a
Time you understand the bigger picture
here right like do you really think the
people in liveria wouldn't kill me if
they chose to of course they would he's
like but uh I feed them and I protect
them I keep them safe from whatever
threats are out there so before they
they pray to whatever God they believe
in when they go to sleep at night they
give thanks to me it's like one of the
greatest speeches ever right and then he
tells the name of the Submariner you're
on your own right you threw in your lot
with Reed Richards and then you went to
Thanos and now you show up on my
doorstep asking me for help no sir Dr
Doom is no one's second choice he
literally just rejects him just because
of the fact that he felt like he was a
second choice it was an amazing moment
in in Marvel Comics but the thing about
this is that as he talks to them he does
know that at any point in time his own
citizenry could literally rise up
against him but it's the fact that it's
happened that now he questions everybody
so he tells them all you're going to
prove to me that I should trust you and
as each person goes in turn and provides
their own swearing of loyalty to Dr Doom
we meet up with a guy named Vasily uh
mccaf I think is how you pronounce his
name and it's one of these things
because as Dr Doom starts asking him
questions like you know how in the world
do you think this happened how do you
think this this whole coup took place
the response of facility as well as
obviously traitors in our midst right
subverting our security different things
like that and doom says allow me to read
you something and what ended up
happening here is that Doctor Doom reads
a letter that was written by Vasily to
basically a woman named Katarina who is
a Sim cardio and so that's when Dr Doom
and really Vasily starts to realize
Doctor Doom already knows vasily's one
of the traitors that he's one of the
people who worked again against Dr Doom
in order to orchestrate orchestrate the
coup d'etat in latviria and so once this
comes to fruition Vasily can't really
lie like he can't really make anything
up right it's at this point if Dr Doom
asks him what do you know about this
letter assume it's rhetorical assume he
already knows the answer and so that's
when Vasily is just like okay right The
Jig Is up like there's nothing he could
do and Dr Doom tells him I'll give you a
two-minute running start this guy hauls
ass out the door because he knows Doctor
Doom well enough to know he's not
messing around Dr Doom walks out there
and at one minute 59 seconds the clock
strikes two minutes he fires the shot
and kills Vasily on the spot and then
he's like feed him to my bear and like
that's it that's how Dr Doom gets things
done guys right it's it's I love how
he's handled I love the way Christopher
Cantwell writes Doctor Doom here it's
absolutely phenomenal but the other part
of this is he actually ends up meeting
with Victorious now he knows Victorious
well enough to know there's no way she'd
be involved in a coup d'etat against him
right so for for you know to a degree
she kind of gets a pass but what he does
is he presents her with the ultimate
nullifier and says the ultimate
nullifier takes an astronomically
focused mind in order to use it
otherwise the user will destroy
themselves or accidentally cause any
manner of things to come to an end so
I'm giving it to you to hold on to for
safekeeping because my mind is not as
focused as it used to be but then
following that he travels directly to
his castle in latviria and it's one of
the coolest moments because when the
coup d'etat took place a guy named
Dimitri fortunov was basically put in
charge of ladveria as the new ruler of
the Kingdom he's more of a puppet than
anything else kind of the guy who's
there to make it look like he's running
the show when in reality he's just being
told what to do so basically any
American politician and the reality of
this is that when Doctor Doom shows up
he's just kind of like the ruler of
latviria an impressive title Dimitri
right an impressive title you must carry
it with dignity stand up straight after
all your king and hold your head high he
who Reigns looks down on those who don't
but something's missing yes a true
leader must have this and that's when Dr
Doom removes his helmet and shows his
face and says if you are going to be the
leader of Liberia this is what you must
look like and he forces this guy to
start cutting his own face up right to
disfigure his own face and then he
turned he says the ruler of latviria
must also be a god Dimitri right can you
fly as a god flies and then he throws
him over the banisters and the guy falls
to his death and he's like alas a mere
mortal quite the pity but then in that
moment he actually ends up getting a
vision of his kids from the alternate
reality but they've cut their faces up
to look like him and the view of it is
so astronomically crushing to him that
he actually sort of collapses on the
spot right he almost passes out from the
strain because remember these visions
that he has of his kids of the life that
he could have is what he aspires to it's
what he wants it's almost like this life
is unsullied by everything that exists
out there in the world right now and so
what he does is he kind of gives us this
little bit of a monologue where he says
that over time you know once he was met
by Victorious and I wouldn't say nursed
back to health but Victorious was able
to help him regain his bearings Dr Doom
basically sits like he literally takes
his throne back and with him having the
ultimate nullifier one of the things to
understand is the world is scared out of
its wits now under any normal
Circumstance the world would look at
Doctor Doom retaking labyria with a bit
of a question of a lie and just kind of
be like can't we really trust this guy
but the dude's got the ultimate
nullifier in his possession and Dr Doom
as far as the world is concerned albeit
the world doesn't know the current
goings-on of his mental state but doctor
but the world sees Dr dooman believes
this guy having the ultimate nullifier
is enough to literally Wipe Out the
entirety of the universe like that in
the blink of an eye and so no one really
questions what it is that he wants and
in fact he goes as far as to say like
now that I've taken my Throne back I
don't want to conquer the world I don't
want to take over the world I have no
Grand aspirations for anything like that
but what I am going to do is I'm going
to put down this Rebellion that had
taken place in that area I'm going to
Route out everybody who was from
sincaria that caused this coup d'etat in
the first place and then I'm going to
take some karya and that's going to be
it and the world doesn't stand in his
way so literally this guy launches an
attack against the neighboring country
and let me tell you something man this
guy sun sun sun they they were not
prepared this guy comes in and it's just
like it's it's hell it's fire in
Brimstone right it's Old Testament man
this guy comes in and he's literally
like I seized control of this entire
country I conquered everything right he
says like the Sim cardian invasion was
over quickly my blood became charged
with the Verve as we stamped out every
conspiratorial smudge of scum every
Whisper of usurping vermin I even dusted
off my old Blaster buggy which is an
actual thing that he used to have back
in the day I haven't driven in ages what
fun it was to lay waste to so much at
such invigorating speeds here was Doom
at his greatest I am a strong proponent
of Total War and no quarter if you're
going to break the back of an entire
nation you might as well do it right we
even killed most of the livestock they
just cleaned slated Sim cardia and it
was as much of a message as it was
anything else this guy goes full-on
Kaiser sosai right I don't know if we
ever ran over that right but like Kaiser
so it's like the story of Kaiser so say
is amazing we're going to kind of scroll
comment panel so you guys to see what's
going on but the story of Kaiser sose is
amazing because for those of you guys
who never heard about this it was from
The Usual Suspects right and it's
literally Kevin Spacey who gives the
story and he says that Kaiser so say it
was just like this drug Runner right
this guy that ran like a small little
drug operation and that was it but you
had these these Hungarian Warlords that
wanted to basically make a name for
themselves and what they knew is that
true power is not how much you have and
how much you control it's about your
willingness to do what the other guy
wants so these Hungarian Warlords I
think they were Hungarian basically show
up at uh Kaiser sose's home they find
his wife and kids right they basically
do what they will with his family and
when Kaiser sose gets back he finds his
wife has been violated and his kids are
crying and so these guys literally tell
them we want your whole operation we
want it all we want the drugs the money
we want your contacts the whole nine
yards right they wanted to show Kaiser
so say that they were that they were men
of will that they were willing to do
whatever it took and so Kaiser so say
showed these men of will just what will
really was this guy killed his wife and
his kids and then he executed every
single one of the Hungarian Warlords
except for one and then he let that guy
go and tell the tale and then once all
these guys like once once his family was
buried then he goes to work right he
killed these Hungarian Warlords parents
he killed their parents friends he
burned down the homes that they lived in
he burned down the businesses they
worked out of he killed the people who
owed them money and then he vanished and
that was it right you never found out
what happened to Kaiser so say if that
well you do but you got to watch The
Usual Suspects to find out that's
literally what this is man that's
literally what this is it's like that
guy said to John Lithgow and that movie
Ricochet you didn't beat him you just
pissed him off and now you cause
now he's gonna be out for blood and so
what we end up doing here is we
basically switch over to Doctor Doom
basically finding Katarina right after
the letter that he read to the silly he
ends up taking one of his swords him and
Katarina getting a sword fight he cuts
her down and that's the end of it
following that Katarina tells him I'm
not the one who started the coup d'etat
in latviria from sankaria I'm not the
one who caused it instead she points him
to the to the person who did and what he
ends up revealing is that as a woman
he's never met he doesn't know who she
is doesn't know what she's about but
ultimately these people launched the
Rebellion against Dr Doom from some from
some karya to seize control of latviria
and that this woman herself had a
daughter and the daughter that she had
was basically Left Behind when this
woman fled after her husband was killed
This Woman's been in some cardia ever
since and been plotting to overthrow
Doctor Doom but her daughter was taken
by the rebel forces that sided with
Doctor Doom and then raised as their own
the girl is Victorious that literally
the number one really the number two
commander of doctor Doom's Army actually
has some Korean blood now Victorious
wasn't working against doctor do and in
fact she didn't even know her own
Heritage she didn't know that this woman
who had orchestrated this whole and
liveria was her own mom she had no idea
that was the case and so instead what
Doctor Doom does really with with uh
Zora herself is he orders her to kill
this woman after telling Victorious that
this woman is her mom and while
Victorious does follow the orders as
they were given to her at the end of the
day Dr Doom assumed that Victorious
wouldn't really care that she would just
see this woman as some Korean scum as a
rebel right a person who tried to
orchestrate a Revolt instead while it
doesn't necessarily lead Victorious to
Turning against Dr Doom entirely it does
permanently fracture the relationship
between the two of them she doesn't
trust him as much anymore and she
doesn't look at him the same way anymore
following that every single person who
was in some capacity associated with the
coup d'etat in latviria from sincaria
whether they're in La Viria as as
collaborators and orchestrators or
whether they're from sankaria or not it
doesn't matter they're all summarily
executed by firing squad so literally
like Dr Doom takes no prisoners and the
funny thing about this is this kind of
fine will act is what he does is he
Muses to himself and he says despite all
this violence and all these things that
he's done at the end of the day he has
no intention of staying this way that
what he's going to do is he's going to
travel to the Moon he's going to find a
solution to fix this whole antleon
collider problem and then he's going to
become the version of himself that he
saw in his Visions the version of
himself that by all standards of
measurement is much better and far more
peaceful than he is right now and has
led the world into a place where it
becomes more more advanced right
basically ushering ushering in a new era
but notice this Dr Doom's not doing it
because it's the right thing to do none
of it comes from an altruistic motive
he's doing it because he sees it as his
best possible chance to rule the world
and so following this once he completes
all of his research and everything and
literally develops a plan then what he
says is he's kind of devised a whole
like laser and experiment and so on
which is way beyond my ability to
comprehend but basically it keeps
getting fired into the black hole which
will help to reduce the the black hole
in size the problem with this is that
doctor Doom's ego becomes his own
problem that what happens here is that
as he talks to Reed Richards who
literally just wants to wish him good
luck Dr Doom's own ego and really his
own self-consciousness starts to become
an issue when he starts to believe that
Reed has an ulterior motive that reads
just like yeah good luck Doctor Doom
you're gonna need it man because maybe
Reed Richards has realized something
about doctor Doom's experiment that Dr
Doom didn't realize himself but because
of how much he hates Reed and because of
all the insecurity that he has in his
comparison to read that he actually
starts recalculating all of his
experiments he basically starts to
second-guess himself and when that
happens he makes a fatal error because
when he does the machine fires off it
hits the moon and it blows part of the
Moon in half and then following that
Doctor Doom disappears and so when that
happens he basically wakes up in this
alternate reality in this alternate
universe where he's met by his alternate
self and this is where things get really
really cool because as he meets his
alternate reality version of himself he
doesn't really attack him right instead
he's just like I want to learn I want to
know how it was you successfully managed
to conquer the world now notice the
conversation between these two is
starkly different because this good
version of Doom right this we'll call
him Victor right Victor does not use
phrases like here's how I conquer the
world here's how I subjugated Humanity
different things like that it's we and
us it's a collaborative effort from his
perspective whereas Doctor Doom is
seeing it as you did something that
allowed you to seize control of the
entire world and it's one of those cool
things because Adam Brashear survived
everything that had gone on and in fact
he ended up in this alternate reality as
well and what what really uh Adam
Brashear says is that the visions that
Doctor Doom has been having of Victor's
life where he's got a wife and kids and
the world adores him and loves him that
the reality is it's a mirror that what
Victor's been receiving are the is
really the life of Doctor Doom and so
it's one of those things where Victor
looks at Dr Doom and his actions in the
main level universe and being a a kind
of warlord and all that kind of stuff as
a nightmare right he sees it as like the
worst possible version of himself that
he could potentially be whereas Dr Doom
looks at Victor and sees Victor as what
could be the best version of himself but
again the motivations are different
Victor is afraid of the life he would
have as Doctor Doom because he becomes
the warlord Dr Doom loves the life that
Victor has because it allows him to
achieve his ultimate goal as a warlord
so again totally different motivations
totally different perspectives but at
the end of the day they are in some
capacity mirrors of each other and
that's what's so cool here because as
they begin to talk this Victor
personality kind of starts to rub off on
Doctor Doom to a degree right where
Doctor Doom is perceiving all of this as
Victor just because he's so much smarter
than everybody and like that's it but
one of the things Victor says is you're
wrong about that and I want to hear you
say that you're wrong I want to hear you
tell me that you were wrong and the
response of Doom is I was wrong right
and it's really hard for him to say
because he's got to swallow his tried to
do it but then they get to the home of
Victor which is a really nice and
beautiful home but it's not the castle
of doomstadt in Liberia and Doctor Doom
asked Victor like why would you give up
our Birthright why would you give up
this Castle to live in this this kind of
this huffle as he calls it right like
this this small home that just does not
really stand as a testament to the
greatness of who we are and the response
of Victor is because none of this is
about how great I am none of this is
about how awesome and intelligent I is
Victor Von Doom am that's not what this
is supposed to be this was all done for
the legitimate betterment of humanity to
make the world a better place for people
more so than that what he also says is
you are looking at this and you're
really looking at the world from your
own limited perspective you look at it
in terms of what you can make the world
into being I look at the world from the
perspective of what can I and the rest
of humanity turn the world into what can
we make the world because it's one of
those things where he says the result is
that regardless of how you perceive
Humanity what whether you're exceedingly
misanthropic and make this argument that
the human race is the worst thing to
happen to Earth or you're more
optimistic where you say the potential
of humanity far outweighs the terrible
things that we've done the reality is
that the human race is greater than the
sum of its parts as a singular entity
with a singular ideology and a motive
the human race cannot be stopped from
achieving anything but instead it's it's
literally barriers between countries and
its motivations from world leaders right
and different things like that it's the
limited perception of the World by
Humanity that makes Humanity so limited
and so when he's like once you start
breaking that down the possibilities are
endless and what he reveals is it's like
this isn't just Earth where this happens
the every single Race Across the
Universe we all collaborate now the Shia
the cree the scroll the badoon the whole
nine yards we share information We Share
technology that we protect those
civilizations as much as they protect us
and while our technology was vastly more
limited than theirs because Humanity as
a whole had not achieved Interstellar
travel there was a level of power
regarding various superheroes that exist
on Earth that those other other
civilizations didn't have so we let them
have some stuff they let us have some
stuff and the universe is better off for
it and that's what's so fascinating here
because even Victor says like all these
Grand weapons that exist out there and
these Grand Powers the Infinity Stones
The Cosmic Cube the Crimson Gem of
sidorak you know the the casket of
ancient Winters the dark hole there's no
need for those things anymore there's no
need for these crazy you know artifacts
of power because nobody really views the
world in such a limited capacity in that
way anymore we don't need it we do
what's right because it's best for
Humanity and so as this whole
conversation takes place that what
Victor tells Doctor Doom is you can
achieve this you can do this on your own
home world you can literally bring this
world or really bring what I've done to
your own world but you're going to have
to drop this facade you're going to have
to drop this armor that you have you're
gonna have to learn to forgive guys like
Richards and you're gonna have to heal
your face and he says the reason why you
have to heal your face is because you
know just as well as I do at any point
in time you could heal your face you
could restore your face back to a sense
of normalcy but you choose not to
because having a scarred face allows you
to remember how Humanity has wronged you
that instead of becoming one with
humanity and leading Humanity you want
to subjugate the human race because you
see yourself as better than them you are
the very definition of a misanthropic
narcissist right like you believe people
don't matter and they should be
subjected or subjugated because you're
somehow more capable than they are and
he says think about it for a moment
Victor it's all a farce A desperate and
honestly pathetic attempt to conceal
your endless fear it currently permeates
every fiber of your existence all the
way down to the silly finger guns in
your metal Gauntlet hand it's all
ludicrous your entire mode of being is
ludicrous you know that I'm right and
when he says that it's the final straw
Doctor Doom kills Victor on the spot
then he sees his control of the ultimate
nullifier in this alternate reality and
wipes out the whole universe literally
kills the whole universe on the spot he
ends with having you know taking Adam
Brashear out and Adam Bashir arrives
back on Earth but Dr Doom is just like
no I will not have it said that I Dr
Doom Victor Von Doom the smartest being
in existence has somehow joined the
limited intellectual minds of humanity
and I've somehow become a part of them I
don't want to be infected by the human
race I don't want to be that kind of a
person if the human race will become
better it's because I will make them
better I will lead them into becoming
better because I will subjugate them and
turn them into something better but if
Humanity could be better it would have
already been better by now Humanity
doesn't want to be better because people
are stupid but I will make them better
and so it's it's like the most
misanthropic thing ever right but
literally wipes out a whole universe of
the spot kills that entire universe and
then just goes back to his castle and
it's just like nope I'm him like I'm I'm
Doctor Doom there's not one ounce of
good in me and there never ever will be
and that's when Kang reappears to Victor
Von Doom and it's just like so I see
that you're back on your throne and the
response of Victor is yes I will not
become that guy he is a weak muelling
pathetic version of me and that's never
going to be what's gonna happen to
Doctor Doom if I conquer this world
it'll be with an Iron Fist and all all
came to conqueror does is just look on
and basically smile because at the end
of the day I don't know if it was the
manipulation of Kane that led to this
but seemingly King always knew how this
was going to turn out it was simply just
up to Doctor Doom to figure it out on
his own but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
Amazing Story I loved it thank you all
for watching and I'll catch you all
later
peace